thank you so much fans for this fan  favorite award I it means a lot to me I  don't take this for granted company  level and I'm so excited to be in that  car so excited to be involved it truly  is where I felt comfortable and I feel  really at home so thanks for recognizing  that makes being around for it thanks  for voting to that on top of that of  course i would like to thank next car of  like to thank the nationwide insurance  for the series itself in a sponsorship  I'd like to make Chevy Junior  Motorsports for giving me a car to go  show what I can do thank you to go daddy  of course they've been a fantastic  partner somebody that supported me all  along the way especially on my way of  the Cup Series next year thank you to  PSO 2 feet to Hot Wheels you can call  been interrupted sponsors that have also  that have been wonderful thing to say  great mission and I hope that more fan  favorite parts what if it doesn't think  this one and happy thanksgiving and  pieces